les agrumes du soleil à portée de main
une explosion de saveurs et de vitamine
c qui donne un kick aux boissons et
rehaussent les maires mène aux agrumes
contient aussi de l'image aller le gros
problème avec la nasa lui elle c'est un
pesticide qui reconnues cancérigènes
probables
nous sommes chez courchesne la rose
grossistes importateurs et exportateurs
de fruits et légumes frais plus de 6
millions de caisses d'agrumes transitent
ici annuellement
donc c'est écrit que c'est pas seulement
traiter avec les différents produits
donc images à lille
guy milette nous a ouvert la porte de
leur grand entrepôt d'agrumes à tous les
agrumes centre était à l'image du tout
les agrumes
d'où ça vient principalement orange
citron je reviens de partout à travers
le monde principalement de la californie
en saison mais sinon aussi du mexique le
maroc est un gros fournisseur d'agrumes
sur toutes les machines l'espagne devenu
un joueur très important
l'afrique du sud le chili le brésil le
pérou également maintenant peu importe
le pays d'origine
à l'exception des producteurs bio on
planche systématiquement les agrumes
dans un mélange d'eau de cire et de
fongicides pour éviter notamment lors du
transport qui est de la pourriture qui
développe des mois sur des champignons
donc c'est strictement dans un but de
conservation lock et ça va permettre aux
produits d'avoir une durée de vie
beaucoup plus acceptable pour des
consommateurs et ça va aider la grume 1
a gardé une fermeté sans fongicide qui
est utilisée selon des normes très
précises
en fait depuis 2014 la norme
internationale déclaration obligatoire
sur les produits qui sont utilisés et on
retrouve à des notes sur les caisses que
ce soit peu importe la marque
ces déclarations qui sont obligatoires
[Musique]
par contre le consommateur ne le sait
pas puisque il n'y a aucune obligation
de l'indiquer sur les étals quand le
fouillis sorti sa caisse
l'épicerie a décortiqué 3 rapport annuel
du programme national de surveillance
des résidus chimiques dans les fruits et
légumes locaux et importés constat tous
les agrumes contiennent des traces dit
maza libre même si règle générale les
normes sont respectées 3% des citrons et
autres agrumes sont quand même arrivés
au canada avec des traces d'image à
lille dans des proportions trop élevé 3
% semble peu mais c'est quand même
l'équivalent de près de 15 millions de
kilos d'agrumes en circulation qui
dépasse les noms professeur en santé
environnementale
maryse bouchard a participé à de
nombreuses études internationales sur
les dangers liés aux pesticides penser
que du matériel a été associé à des
cancers notamment du foie chez les
animaux de laboratoire qui était exposée
chez lui mais la différence c'est que on
est exposés à des concentrations sont
beaucoup plus faibles
mais ce qui se passe avec les effets
cancérogènes
c'est qu'on sait que même des doses très
faibles peuvent causer des effets parce
que c'est à long terme développement du
concert c'est quelque chose qui peut
prendre des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années
de plus l'image à lille serait un
perturbateur endocrinien pouvant déréglé
notre système hormonal
il pourrait avoir aussi un impact
négatif sur le neurodéveloppement de
l'enfant à votre avis est-ce qu'on doit
s'en inquiéter ou pas moi ça m'inquiète
parce que ça se passe à faible dose
d'exposition
il ya ceux qui est qui est difficile à
venir étudier de façon de façon précise
[Musique]
autre aspect à considérer c'est l'effet
cocktail on connaît mal les conséquences
d'un gérer de nombreux pesticides même
en de très petites quantités au
quotidien la notion de risque est
toujours en fonction de l'exposition
dont c'est clair et net que s'il ya des
risques plus élevés sur les citrons par
exemple mais le risque d'être plus élevé
mais il faut quand même qu'on parle que
d'un côté ce temps on les consomme pas
régulièrement et lorsqu'on les aspects
que je pense que les débats de la loi du
coin ce traitement de les laver comme il
faut et de les bras c'est que après
comme la consommation n'est pas très
fréquente pour un effet crohn et les
problèmes devraient somme toute est
assez faible si on reste notre on est ce
qu'on attendait un peu à votre avis on
en enlève une bonne partie mais il reste
une partie qui a été absorbée l'un qui
conte sera pas capable de reims est en
effet l'image à lille ne se retrouve pas
seulement la surface des agrumes il
pénètre aussi dans la chair dans un
ratio de 10 % pour les agrumes apple
huré ps comme la plupart des variétés de
citron d'orange et de pamplemousse et de
25 pour ça pour les agrumes apple sûrs
metz comme la lime ou les clémentines
nous monde idéal je lai est aujourd'hui
on ça serait plaisant d'avoir du frigo
aucun mais dans le contexte de
l'agriculture moderne je crois pas que
ça va être demain kobo vox
on va utiliser encore beaucoup les
pesticides est un moment